the console showing creamer Kobo unity
adopt negotiating directives that gives
opportunity to to our chief negotiator
to continue with the discussion on
transition period with the UK member
states agreed that during the transition
period the whole Union akise should keep
applying in the UK during the transition
period the UK will not longer
participate in the institutions and
decision making process in the u.s after
withdrawal date UK will become a third
country during the transition period the
UK will be expected to comply with EU
trade policy this also means that during
that period the UK will not be able to
have its own international agreements in
areas covered by the EU law the new
position is very clear the transition
will last for 21 months until the 31st
of December 2020 during transition the
UK will continue to take part in a
single market to take part to the custom
union and with all Union policies it
will continue to have all the economic
benefits therefore it must also apply
all the euros the single market cannot
be a la carte the UK will no longer be a
new member on the 29th of March 2019
this will have consequences in terms of
institutions and governance after this
date the UK will no longer participate
in the decision-making process
so the costs on or some decision hotel
in yata the transition